hello party people
I'm Greg Alba now I'm John Humphrey we
are gonna watch The Watchmen cop
you know what I just remember who wants
to watch me comic-con shreds popped into
my head we were at comic-con walking the
ground floor someone came out to us Josh
I believe is his name
we got recognized quite a bit the first
day we were there and one of the first
people his guy named Joshua I asked what
he was you know if he was doing any
specific comic-con he's like yeah I'm
actually the VFX editor for Watchmen
they whoa you watch our [__] we're gonna
be watching your [__] let's go check
this trailer out who watches the
Watchmen trailer we do we do
this world
it's all about optional Virginia King
you don't do lollipops in rain you know
those are pretty colors they just hide
what the world really is back in my bus
they were
[Music]
was you buddy
expel
[Music]
are you maybe yeah listen [__] Mars
curse too much
[Music]
I only just begun
oh wow the owner if that is a definitive
hint that dr. Manhattan is returning
from Mars er just to the story to the
story I mean they definitely had a brief
glimpse of him glowing up there but I
have to imagine that he would come back
to the story in some way if they're
gonna tease us that way especially with
that ending image they had the massive
like okay she's Matt's when they shot
the blue head like ooh maybe Billy
Crudup is the only one returning for
this or maybe this takes place in the
Arrested Development universe when
Tobias turns himself blue anyway the
Watson let's talk all about the marriage
now wondering how this show will
ultimately perform I read something
interesting when we were about to film
this check it John hmm it is from the
description box
Watchmen is based on the traffic novel
co-created illustrated by Dave Gibbons
and published by DC you know I found
fascinating about this Alan Moore's name
Alan Moore his name is nowhere here yeah
it's a glaring omission knew they were
taking inspiration from the original
graphic novel and they want to do like
their own new thing so there's not
really a whole bunch of source material
that's gonna be included in this trailer
because a lot of its gonna just be
completely original and made up and
expanded upon so I wanted to see who was
starring in it then they came across
this description and I was like Alan
Moore must want nothing to do with some
contract out there this is like from now
on if you shoot any of my books just
don't even mention my name yeah I know
he doesn't generally even like the idea
of his graphic novels being adapted I
don't know of any of his work that he
was ultimately satisfied with being
adapted we don't quote me a hundred
percent on that but this doesn't even
feel like Alan Moore in and of itself I
know I'm judging like a whole season of
television off of a three-minute teaser
they were given as there are parts that
I feel like they're trying to be
Watchmen it does feel more Damon
Lindelof than Alan yeah yeah yeah which
I have to just accept I just gotta roll
with it and it still looks cool
yeah I like the concept of what they're
trying to do while at the same time it
makes me very wary just because Damon
Lindelof I think has a lot of
interesting ideas but go on to any
comment thread and I'm sure people will
be bitching about his ability to tie up
a complete story of a payoff different
threads but just from the jumping-off
point of yeah we're basing this on
Watchmen but we're gonna update the
themes and kind of tailor it to now I
like the concept in the images they're
showing just the tonal mishmash they
have going on it feels very scopic and
political and paranoid like Regina Kings
the means are this was good for her
match what I'm finding really
interesting about the marketing for this
I don't know how much the fan base for
the Watchmen movie has developed since
it first came out I pulled the numbers
up right here the movie costs a hundred
thirty million dollars just to make it
so I mean including the marketing which
was awesome marketing the best parts of
it domestically made a hundred seven
million dollars and foreign made 77
million so it definitely didn't make its
money back and while the aesthetic
design of the movie who's obviously
trying to rip the pages directly I can't
just sit here and say the show is
drawing inspiration from the movie
because it said the movies technically
just wanted to be exactly the comic
until the end yeah it's time to pay it
all off exactly they said that this show
was supposed to follow after the movie
they've said that it seemed like as
Jeremy Irons is a pretty good match for
Matthew good cuz yeah there were changes
they made to the ending of the Watchmen
movie and then this show supposed to
follow whatever the ending changes were
in the Watchmen movie and so to that
degree yeah I'm kind of a few questions
that are kind of raised with the
marketing of this if you don't know
Watchmen at all if you've never read the
graphic novel if you've never seen the
movie I feel like you're just gonna
watch this trailer and be like what the
hell going under set because even as
someone who's read and watched the
question I know odd amigos I don't know
what's going on yeah I'm kind of good
for you pick it up bits and pieces here
and there but I don't fully know what's
happening here the Rorschach based
movement the police are wearing masks
now Adrian Veidt
still doing his rich guy thing yes and
Regina Kings kicking ass not arguments
that symbol isn't happening here the
nature of uh how do you tell a cop from
a superhero yeah I don't know so it's
like yeah well I'll pick it up with some
themes I just it seems like this show is
gonna depend so heavily on the mythology
you already have to be aware of in order
to grasp this series and is that really
the wisest move considering that the
Watchmen movie was a flop it seems like
it's gathered a bigger following over
time and Watchmen has a timeless classic
comic book graphic like it's graphic
novel is like consider like one of the
best one of the best you know it's like
up there as being just a great novel
they you know not just graphic novels
yeah exactly
so while it has that installed there's
still gonna be plenty of people who
haven't done it either of those and I
feel like you got a reintroduced
Watchmen and I feel like the marketing
has done little to nothing to
reintroduce Watchmen nah dude they'll do
a five-minute recap montage the very
beginning of the series watch me I feel
like it's easy to watch this stuff me
like I don't think about Watchmen I'm
not gonna watch your show that's fair I
mean I feel like the most striking thing
about this particular trailer is just
the array of images the true like where
who were we gonna follow specifically
what is the plot exactly gonna be for
this new take I feel like if something
people would want a better sense of
because this is already like a tall
order in a more ideal scenario because a
lot of people have said Watchmen should
be a miniseries rather than a movie
because it's so dense with ideas I feel
like you have to win over the people who
are already skeptical because they know
Watchmen and they know that this could
easily go wrong and you have to win over
the people who just don't know it at all
ya know and so yeah you have to win over
those hardcore fans who know that alan
moore has no involvement in this and are
just gonna refuse to check it out you
know which you're not going to do yeah
maybe put on V for Vendetta
you're like man I'm gonna give it a shot
though I mean I have HBO so might as
well check it out
I mean personally yes I will I really
want to see what they do with this the
best that this could be sounds really
cool so if they nail their potential I
would be psyched yeah this has got to be
really well-written as well are you guys
excited for Watchmen do you have high
hopes for it are you nervous sceptical
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects please click that
notification bell hey I would like to
give a patron the day shout out to a man
named Joshua waka he says to us he's an
X video editor from the UK who now
spends most of his spare time cosplaying
and I pretty much said well thank you
now I'm definitely going to include
these cosplay photos in here first up we
got him here as Thor you know fat Thor
with a Stormbreaker I don't know if
you're actually overweight I'm calling
the Pharaoh Thor character fat Thor or
growth or gamer Thor there's a whole
debate about not saying you're fat I'm
saying you're cosplaying as what is
bitcoin is the overweight Thor and then
from Deadpool - you got fat PETA you got
Peter Peter with a sick baby was
actually these look great yeah look
awesome
did you grow that he's about to ask that
looks like a really authentic the word
beard looks very real and the mustache
looks like you definitely put that
together
you must really grow the facial hair
wigs that were great mm-hmm do you make
them yourself just coming back from
comic-con it's like yeah I have a huge
admiration now for cosplay oh yeah and
then you got this third one you sent us
not gonna lie
no idea who this is it's on the tip of
my tongue I feel like I should be able
to name it but I can't cuz I'm a I'm not
a good nurse Adam tell curry no but yeah
I'm gonna go with Valkyrie old are deaf
they'll Kurd are it's a mishmash it's a
crossover character I don't know where
people can follow you Josh but leave a
comment and we'll find it and we'll like
it and then hopefully at least enough
people to checking out of that
and going are I will follow him on in
sir thank you so much Josh being part of
a patreon page keep saying us cosplay
photos as you look great
do one of us where you where you're both
of us